sin movimiento que no se puede contener
fueron miles los que marcharon este
sábado en melbourne en unas protestas
que en su mayoría fueron calificadas
como violentas según la policía del
estado de victoria
esta movilización llega después de que
el sexto confinamiento de la ciudad se
ampliará a todo el estado
es la política que ha seguido a
australia en la pandemia cerrarse ante
el repunte de contagios pero ya con una
evidente repercusión en las calles
y la otra ciudad más grande del país a
mi nuevo marchas aunque a una escala
ligeramente menor aquí el confinamiento
se extendió hasta finales de septiembre
deberían avergonzarse en esta ciudad se
registraron la mayoría de los 894
contagios de todo el país de ese sábado
un nuevo récord que llegue de la mano de
la variante delta pero con sólo el 30
por ciento de la población con el
esquema de vacunación completo no más a
huff no importa si el 99 por ciento de
las personas están haciendo lo correcto
nadie puede controlar el elemento de la
variante delta y es lo que tenemos que
aceptar y la mejor manera de protegernos
la mejor manera en la que podemos
anhelar la libertad es asegurándonos que
nos vacunamos uy que thaksin aire con
una población de 25 millones de personas
y poco menos de mil fallecidos
australia es uno de los países con las
tasas de muertos por millón de
habitantes más bajas del mundo